und zugeschaltet ist torsten reinwald
sprecher des deutschen jagdverbandes
guten abend was geht ihnen denn bei
diesen bildern durch den kopf ja guten
abend erstmal also ich habe die fotos
jetzt das videomaterial das erste mal
gesehen
das geht mir auch schon an die nieren
muss ich sagen ich kann zu dem
einzelfall jetzt nicht sagen aber mit
einer offenen halle zu jagen ohne
verblendung und dann die katze einfach
auch zu erschießen die offensichtlich
wohlgenährt ist die wahrscheinlich auch
ein besitzer hat das ist recht
fragwürdig aber im einzelfall muss das
gericht entscheiden was da jetzt zu tun
ist
man darf denn ein jäger überhaupt eine
katze erschießen
ich glaube da gehören so zentrale
eigenschaften dazu mitgefühl
verantwortung und fingerspitzengefühl
ich selber jage auch im stadtnahen
bereich und ich habe in meinem ganzen
leben noch keine einzige katze getötet
ich versuche dann lieber den kontakt zu
den vermeintlichen besitzern oder am
besten ist wenn ich so eine katze so
eine wohlgenährte katze finde dann
bringe ich sie zum ordnungsamt zum
fundbüro damit der besitzer ermittelt
werden kann
aber wenn wir jetzt mal nur auf die
rechtliche lage sehen ist es durchaus
erlaubt dass jäger katzen erschießen
genau das kommt von ist von bundesland
zu bundesland unterschiedlich wenn sich
eine katze zwischen 200 und 500 meter
entfernt von einer siedlung dann kann
sie getötet werden weil katzen zu
einigen die verwilderten katzen eine
große gefahr darstellen für die
artenvielfalt was die
weltnaturschutzunion ordnet die katze
den hauskatze ein oder den top 40
gefährlichsten invasiven arten und wir
haben in deutschland 2,5 millionen bis
sie zahllose katzen und da geht es eben
auch wieder um das thema verantwortung
da sind die katzenbesitzer gefragt ihre
tiere zu sterilisieren lassen und eben
auch zu registrieren
damit wir diesen diesen pool an
verwilderten katzen endlich austrocknen
diese zweieinhalb millionen katzen diese
verwilderten ohne besitzer fressen jedes
jahr über 100 millionen vögel und
deutlich über 20 millionen kleine
säugetiere also verwilderte katzen
durchaus eben auch eine bedrohung für
die natur und für wildlebende tiere
zurück zu diesem fall diese katze saß ja
jetzt bereits in einer falle die hätte
man ja einfach dem tierheim übergeben
können beispielsweise darf denn eine
katze wenn sie schon in so einer falle
sitzt überhaupt noch getötet werden
also wenn ich ein tier fangen dann kann
ich es danach auch töten lebendfallen
verblendete also dunkle leben fallen
werden beispielsweise eingesetzt
für den fang von waschbären wir haben
von der eu die aufgabe war schwer
aufzufangen ihren bestand einzudämmen
weil sie eben andere tiere bedrohen
das ist jetzt aus jeder sicht nichts
ungewöhnliches
in so einem fall wenn ich eine eine
wohlgenährte katze vor mir habe
die vielleicht gelang halsband trägt
dann verbietet sich das also ich kenne
keinen jäger der auf ein tier schießt
das einen namen hat oder eventuell eine
kleine besitzer das ist
verantwortungslos hereinholt vielen
herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren